[Musique]
christian entre dans cette grotte et
n'en ressortira que dans 40 jours avec
14 autres volontaires âgés de 27 à 50
ans ils ont décidé de se couper du monde
ici il ne fait que 12 degrés et le taux
d'humidité est de 95%
cette expédition est une première
mondiale l'objectif étudiait les
capacités d'adaptation de l'être humain
à la perte de repères spatio-temporels
on va représenter ce que petits groupes
humains va devoir faire si un jour il se
retrouve dans un nouveau territoire
trouver des solutions pour s'installer
en cherchant ce qui est à sa disposition
pour survivre quatre tonnes de matériel
ont été fournies aux bénévoles mais sans
montre sans téléphone ni lumière
naturelle
ils vont devoir apprendre à vivre
ensemble confiné ne pas confiné au
niveau local ou national la question se
pose de plus en plus fortement le nombre
de patients hospitalisés en réanimation
est en hausse de 10% par rapport à la
semaine dernière avec plus de 4100
malade aujourd'hui dont plus d'un quart
sont hospitalisées en ile de france
elle permet de dire à certaines maladies
[Musique]
la vaccination a alors on est dedans on
l'espère moi on m'a appelé alors faire
honte rasé [ __ ] et au combat
intéressant parce qu'il ya des gens qui
avaient pas voulu se faire astrazeneca
parce qu'ils avaient les foi donc si tu
veux il se pose un problème
oui la nido ce qui reste c'est parce que
des gens ont dit ah non non j'ai entendu
qu'astrazeneca c'était dangereux donné
la liebig les et aux mains on my
astrazeneca
je peux vous assurer qu effectuent ainsi
j'avais le moindre doute
si j'avais le moindre de vous demanderez
la suspecte volume en absolument pas ce
que c'est bon de voir c'est ma
responsabilité
bon mais à ce stade et il faut avoir
confiance dans ce vaccin il faut avoir
confiance dans ce vaccin et se faire
vacciner
la décision qui a été prise en
conformité aussi avec notre politique
européenne
c'est de suspendre par précaution la
vaccination avec astrazeneca en espérant
la reprendre vite si la vie de l'om le
permet en 2017 monsieur le président
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus touché la
victoire d'emmanuel maquereau ou la
romande stade à la remontée des châsses
était encore président quand ça s'est
produit
ouais je me souviens c'était à dîner
officiel et on me donnait des résultats
au fur et à mesure et je n'arrivais pas
y croire
pas davantage aux maquereaux donc voyez
vous êtes un homme de théâtre vous aimez
la sienne est ce que vous avez regardé
la cérémonie des césars pendant
l'histoire
non non je crois que j'ai bien fait la
cérémonie s'est terminée à minuit 40
et voilà ce qu'on peut lire dans la
presse depuis une image accablante du
cinéma français titre le figaro à sa une
aujourd'hui en pages intérieures et les
césars du ridicule
une cérémonie du
indigent ce record du début des c-17
cérémonies jusqu'à la fin je me suis
emmerdé haut possible
c'était pas drôle et c'était si tu dis
que les producteurs n'étaient pas au
courant de dollars d'aidé des sketches
qui allaient nîmes enfin pardon si une
faute professionnelle dans mes baskets
ans après celui je vous dise la vérité
c'est très compliqué par la main je vous
le dis les césar j'aimerais garder
et alors c'est à l'image de ce que je
vis aux victoires de la musique aussi
une espèce d'entre eux soit puis c'est
alors qu'on doit être entre nous
d'ailleurs ça fait je crois à millions 6
ouais ça veut dire qu'il ya 66 millions
de français il y en a avec 64 millions
qui sont pas tes couilles en fait pour
moi c'est cette merde quoi j'aime le
cinéma j'ai pas envie de voir cette
espèce de laideron avec ça
et ça c'est pas dégueulasse mais moi je
dois dire que même en dehors de corinne
masiero les robes je ne sais pas ce que
vous en avez pensé mais la plupart eh
ben pour celle qui top la plupart des
robes étaient totalement même un
regardable enfin pour celles qui étaient
un peu difficile de conclure en quoi
c'est sexy mais vous jugez pas tant son
physique madame je suis sélectionné je
parle dans la folie générale elle arrive
enfin dans leur magnifique
la phrase la plus sexiste entendu en
politique c'est un florilège des phrases
sexiste mais je retiendrai celle qui m'a
accompagné quand je suis monté pour la
première fois la tribune de l'assemblée
nationale qui a voilà le concert des
vagins elle est pas mal celle là une
étude réalisée par l'ifop pour sos
racisme et l'uejf fait beaucoup de bruit
et le début de l'article le jdd prévient
les questions sont parfois dérangeante
mais l'objectif est clair et utile
mesurer les préjugés et la prééminence
du racisme dans la société
quelles sont la demande et donc aux
sondés quelles sont les catégories de
personnes que vous jugez trop nombreuses
en france et selon ceux qui ont répondu
eh bien pour 50% de ceux qui ont répondu
les roms sont trop nombreux 43% les
musulmans 43% les maghrébins 40% les
étrangers en général
23% des noirs les asiatiques c'est
seulement 12% si j'ose dire les
catholiques 9% les juifs 8% les
protestants 7% gay à faire croire qu'il
ya du racisme d'une part et d'autre part
à exciter les différences et les haines
entre les gens ce sondage sert à ça le
jdd et la pravda de macron monsieur
belattar était le bouffon du roi il a
servi macron oui c'est ça va dans le bon
sens
quand je marche normale il par un goût
de gêne quand je parle de ma vie c'est
comme un conte d'aigreur chez les hommes
de l'an 2000
mais guillaume bigot
c'est pas le débat deuxième si c'est des
journées des camps des macros on le sait
que sur ces news long tunnel où vous
dites que de la merde moi ici je dois
vous répondre 1 2 vous porter très bien
votre nom je vais vous dire le troisième
pourrait la série mike batteur départ
j'essaye de mails faveur d'un niveau si
vous insultez
[Musique]
il n'y a pas en fait de privilèges blanc
par contre il ya un privilège noir parce
que le simple la simple qualité d'être
noir vous octroient des prébendes et des
privilèges qui ne sont octroyés à eau à
aucune autre couleur on n'irait pas sur
ce terrain là moi j'avais way chant
classique
on dirait que j'ai pas de coeur au fond
de moi j'ai un café ça me coûte la vie